Vår strategi är att verkligen sätta kundeupplevelsen nummer ett och alltid som extra tri.
Det kommer att vara en helt annan strategi mot övriga basteföretag som bara är duktiga på produkt, har ett distributionstätverk, skickar ut det här till Bauhaus och de i sin tur säljer, men man bryr sig aldrig om kundens.
Make Sweden Stronger Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Man sa det omsökt 160 miljoner.
Kan du inte ta...
Du vet, vem du är typ.
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har redan dess bra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig, och det finns inga tugna ögonblickar jag har.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Ja, välkomnar vi Sebastian Sandlund från Bast Sauna till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Du var en av de efterfrågade gästerna.
Jag gick ut och frågade vilka man ville se i podden och då var det ni som dök upp.
Varför tror du att folk bryr sig om er?
Vad är det folk gillar?
Det är en jättebra fråga.
Jag har absolut inget bra svar på det.
Men det är väl att det kanske är en lite spännande produkt och en väldigt spännande marknad just nu med bastubranchen.
Så det är väl både att det kan vara lite utmaningar hur man hanterar en ny produkt på marknaden och så igenom det.
Men sen är det väl också att vi är sjukt sköna killar.
Vi kan väl bara säga lite snabbt att ni säljer, säger jag fel om jag säger att ni säljer bastu-tält, men det är liksom portabla grejer som man kan plocka upp och ner.
Man kan ta med sig det ut till sjön och man kan ta tillbaka och liknande.
Ja exakt, det är så enkelt som det låter.
Det är en bastu i ett tall.
Men sen när man börjar grotta ner sig i produkten med någon specifikation så blir det väl lite mer komplicerat.
Men summa summarum, det är en bastu i ett tält.
Är det en trend som har funnits länge eller var ni med i starten av den här trenden?
För nu finns det väl några som säljer bastu i ett tält men är ni liksom OGs eller är ni copycats?
Det är en bra fråga.
Jag skulle säga att hela bakgrunden till bastu i ett tält, om man så går riktigt långt tillbaka så finns det något som heter Sweat Lodges i USA som har funnits i flera hundratals år och bastukulturen har lite olika skep, beroende på vilken kultur man är i.
Det finns i Mellan, Öster och Mänt, som gick med bastutält ganska mycket.
Men när det kommer till den kommersiella biten, vi har hört från många farser, som bara, men fan när jag körde lumpen då bastade vi mycket i tält och det funkade skitbra.
Och sen var det ett ryskt bolag som startade för ungefär femton år sedan, tio år sedan kanske.
Men inte så att de sprede till den stora breda masten som vi kanske gjorde när vi fick idén för tre år sedan.
Och sen när vi fick idén för tre år sedan har vi dykt upp en hel erorika bastu på marknaden.
Så det var väl vi som fick folk att börja inse att det här är en riktigt bra produkt.
Och kan du inte ta oss, vi kan ta en liten snabb, du har ju berättat storyn i lite olika, men är det liksom, ni var tre personer, ni ville ha en bastu, ni tog en presentning, vi testade det, insåg att det rök lite för mycket där inne och sen så skaffade ni en skorsten.
Hur liksom drog ni igång produktionen?
Ja men det var väl från att vi fick första idéen till att det borde finnas bastutält.
Så då gick det ganska snabbt.
Vi fick faktiskt tag på ett par ryska bastutälten för att vi kunde hyra dem i Stockholm.
Så vi hyrade dem en helg, satte upp det och fick basta första gången och insåg att vad fan, det här är hur bra som helst.
Varför vet inte vi som älskar att basta, varför vet inte vi det om det här.
Så det var väl där det började.
Vi insåg ganska snabbt att det finns några ganska bra affärer där också.
Så vi började undersöka lite på Alibaba om att ta in de första samplen.
Så vi tog in de första samplen, så jag tror vi tog in åtta stycken täl och åtta stycken kaminer.
Och vi hade väl en tanke om att vi skulle välja det tält och den kaminerna med bäst förmöjliga marginal.
Men så var det inte fallet.
Utan vi var tvungna att välja den absolut bästa kvaliteten av absolut dyraste tält och kamin, för det var bara den som kom med riktigt bra bastig upplevelse.
Så det var där vi började, när vi hade tält och kamin började vi göra små ändringar hela tiden.
Och till slut kom vi väl fram till med våra första produkter som vi gjorde en beställning om hundra bastigfält till att börja med.
Och sen gick det lite snabbare än vi tänkte och det fanns en fin marknad för det väldigt tidigt.
Men när vi insåg att vi verkligen ska testa och köra det här, det var när vi hade fått vårt första sample.
Och sen var vi ut i Tantolunden här i Stockholm som är ett väldigt populärt gångstråk.
Så det var en folksamling när vi bara skulle testa bastigtältet i ungefär fyra timmar.
Så vi fick 70 personer som ville vara en spåkare bara under de fyra timmarna.
Så det var då vi ba, men fan vi testar, vi kör, vi köper in hundra stycken och i värsta fall så har vi julklappar till släkt och vänner.
Ni var på en strand och så dök folk upp och ville köpa.
Jag hade ju inte gått fram till någon och bara tja, får jag köpa era tält?
Det känns skumt, vad är det för område?
Det är lite pummer område i Stockholmsk returne.
65 personer var inte så legita kunder.
Jag vill också ha ett tält.
Men av de som sa att de skulle köpa, de 70-60 mejlade resten, jag tror att det kanske var 5 som köpte.
Så det var ändå en relativt hög hitrate på det.
Men jag tror att varför folk kom fram var för att det var så många som ställde sig ifrån.
Vad är det här?
Är det en bastun?
För de såg att det var ett rökrör som kom ut från kaminen och såg att vi gick ut och in med bapabyxor och det var en dag, jag tror det här var under april, så de tyckte att det var helt sjuka i huvudet.
Känns det som att många som bara var på vad är det här?
Så var det många som gick fram och ställde frågan till oss.
Jag förstår hur det var nu.
Vi får se om detta kommer med i podden.
Men Christoffer får avgöra det här.
Ni är ju tre ganska fagra pojkar.
Var det framförallt kvinnor som var med i banvagnen som kom fram och pratade?
Var det så det fungerade?
Det var kvinnor och så var det farsor i Stockholm.
Nej, jag har ju två små barn.
När jag var ut och gick varje kväll med banvagnen, då var det aldrig någon som hälsade på mig.
Men min fru sa alltid att alla kommer alltid fram och säger hej.
Och liksom pratar och hur mår barnet.
Fan jag har gått med den jävla banvagnen 400 gånger, det är aldrig någon som har hälsat.
Jag tror att det beror mycket på vem som...
Hade jag suttit i det här Bastuteltet och kommit ut, då hade fan ingen velat köpa det Bastuteltet av mig.
Jag är hyggligt säker på det.
Jag tror inte det helt och hållet för vi har...
Vi kanske kommer komma in på det här lite senare, men vi har bland annat en contentpartner som har lagt ut en video på Bastuteltet och vi har hört att det är jättemånga av våra befintliga kunder nu som har sett på den videon och sen köpt på grund av att det verkligen är denna autentiska känslan.
Det är inte bara tre unga grampa som är någorunda bältränade, utan det är denna autentiska bastutänslan.
Så jag tror att den är nästan ännu viktigare att förmedla och kommunicera för oss när vi kommer att hitta målgruppen.
Ja, jag har ju sett lite på er material.
Men vi kan komma till det sen...
Jag tänker att vi kan börja till att ni verkar ha haft ganska fin...
Du skrev något inlägg här för några veckor sen om att ni har haft en ganska fin utveckling.
För det är en grej att gå från hobby och så säljer man de här första hundra.
Och sen tror jag att det är ganska många som tänker att nu, nu jävlar, nu tar det fart, nu ska vi dra igång.
Och där någonstans stannar det av.
Men ni verkar ju först ha kommit upp till 10 miljoner och sen har ni liksom lyckats tredubbla det.
Det är ju på något sätt en rätt tuff utveckling att gå igenom.
Kan du inte snacka lite om senast året här, vad som har hänt?
Jag trodde på honom om vi tittade tillbaka på hela 2025.
Jag gick över heltid som första i teamet i mars.
Och sen övriga två grundare, Victor och Josef.
Josef gick över i juni och Viggo gick över i september.
Är Viggo minst viktig för teamet eller varför fick han komma sist?
Han var restaurangjägare här i Stockholm.
Sälja restaurang är inte det enklaste.
Men han hittade en köpare och sen när det var klart så kunde han gå över och köra buss på hela tiden.
Men jag tror att mycket han har handlat om från de första början att vi verkligen prioriterar de initiativen där vi har fått ut mest på grund av att tid har varit ganska begränsat när vi bara gjort det här på sidan om våra vanliga jobb.
Så vi har fokuserat väldigt mycket på det som funkar väldigt bra.
Några exempel på det är att vi har ställt upp ads och vår adsbudget är väldigt aggressivt skulle jag säga.
Så det är väl den enskilt viktigaste faktorn varför vi har lyckats tripla omsättningen under 2025.
Det är kopplat med ett partnernätverk som fungerar bra.
Vi inser att det första steget i en kundresa är att man testar basutatet.
För man måste testa innan man litar på att det faktiskt funkar.
Så vi byggde ut ett partnernätverk i hela Europa där det finns utgynning i runt 200 städer i Europa idag där man kan hyra basutatet.
Det har varit ett av våra absolut viktigaste initiativ.
För idag har vi kunnat sprida basutatet till så många som möjligt och få så många som möjligt att fästa för första gången.
Så det har också gjort att den här upplevelsen som vi hade i Antolunden, den har vi försökt duplicera runtom i hela Europa genom partners.
Så jag skulle säga att vi har skalat upp och verkligen doubled down på det som har funkat och gjort att vi har kunnat växa så snabbt och så tidigt.
Men det absolut viktigaste är att vi har en väldigt bra produkt.
Där partnernetverket, där man kan hyra tältet, är det er affär eller har de köpt tält av er och så har ni godkänt att de får hyra ut?
Hur ser den setaten ut?
Vi har lite olika definitioner av partners.
Vi har ju återförsäljare som vi jobbar med också.
Vi jobbar bland annat med Tyskland och Österrikes största Bastudistributör.
De misstintar runt 30 butiker i Tyskland och Österrika.
Sen har vi våra egna återförsäljare som har uppställt det i butik.
Det är runt 70 återförsäljare som vi har i Europa idag.
Och sen de här utbildningspartnerserna eller de som vi definierar egentligen som Bastpartners.
Det är att man köper ett bastotält av oss till ett rabatterat pris och sen använder man det bastotält för utgivning eller att man använder det som ett eventbolag eller bara få människor att testa bastotältet i någon typ av form.
Och sen har vi också ett incitamentprogram att de verkligen känner att det är värt att visa upp bastotältet så de får provision på all hänvisad försäljning.
Så det har varit ett väldigt bra initiativ som vi har verkligen fokuserat på under hela 2025 och kommer också fortsätta fokusera på det.
Du sa att över hela Europa är det någon som bastar i Portugal och Spanien.
Det är det.
Vi har ju Costa del Sol i Spanien och där är det många exit-svenskar.
Så där har vi en liten hotspot.
Sen har vi upp, vi säljer väldigt mycket i Portugal.
Och kundgruppen i Portugal är främst typ surfare.
Eller de som, för det är ganska kallt i Atlanten och att bada där särskilt under vintern.
Så där har vi sålt en del.
Och Portugal är ett tydligt exempel av vad som har funkat väldigt bra för oss.
Sen vi egentligen startade.
Vi såg det första basutelt i Portugal till det var en snobbe som köpte det.
Och sen såg vi att det kom två till, säger vi.
Och det var hans granna som köpte.
Och det blir verkligen så, när vi säljer ett basutelt egentligen till vem som helst, det blir som en ganska tydligt demotelt.
Där man bjuder in vänner, familj, kollegor och de i sin tur spider basuteller på ett fint sätt för oss.
Men blir det tydligt att det är liksom exvilsvenskar och exvilsvänskar, eller för jag bodde i Portugal under ett par år och jag jobbade på ett hotell som massör en sommar åt en finska som drev ett hotell där nere.
Och hon hade givetvis en bastu.
Och det var ju 40 grader på sommar men hon skulle basta ändå.
Det var ju liksom standard typ.
Men jag bara intalar mig att alla de som köper där nere, de har någon sorts svenskt, norskt, finskt påbrå.
Eller är det äkta portugiser som börjar basta?
Jag har bara svårt att se portugiserna sitta där.
Nej men jag förstår att man har svårt att se det framför sig, men vad som är, eller vad som sker just nu, det är att det också är en bastoboom runtom i hela världen och även i, kanske främst i Europa.
Och kanske främst de här marknaderna där man inte har haft en bastokultur sedan tidigare.
Så vi ser att det är en tydlig boom och det har också därför gått så bra som det har gått för oss redan nu.
Det är för att vår timing har varit väldigt bra när vi lanserade produkten i och med den här boomen som just nu sker.
Är det en del av den här hälsotrenden med kallbad och infrarött och liknande, ingår det i samma?
Eller är det mer att folk tycker att det här är skönt?
Det är exakt.
Jag skulle säga att Bastu kanske befinner sig i dag där kallbad förfann sig för typ fem år sedan ungefär.
Så det är en tydlig boom som vi ser ganska tydligt.
Sen har vi våran filterboop, som vi alltid är i, så vi kanske inte får en helt sanningsenlig bild av verkligheten.
Men vi märker att det är en tydlig boom.
Er marknadsföring och er hemsida känns mycket mer riktad mot det som du nämnde här i början.
Mycket mer den här att man är med vännerna, man är ut i naturen, man är liksom in i snacket, och man kanske tar en bash och sitter där och snackar.
Det är mycket mer den känslan än att det är bra för återhämtningen och din hy.
Varför har ni sån marknadsföring också?
Det är bara att inte jag får upp den för att jag inte bryr mig.
Vår kommunikation skiljer sig ganska mycket beroende på vilken marknad man är i.
I UK till exempel, där trycker vi ganska mycket på hälsouppdelare, för där är det viktigt för den kunden.
Om vi tar Sverige som ett exempel så är det inte lika viktigt.
Där har vi en bastekultur sedan tidigare, vi vet hur bra vi mår när vi bastar.
Sen finns det forskning som bevisat att det är superbra att basta.
Men det är också väldigt knepig forskning på grund av att det är väldigt svårt att dra några tydliga slutsatser från den forskningen.
Så vi vill inte heller vara det bolaget som kommer att säga va men basta i tio minuter sedan hoppa i nio i svaken i fem väl vill vi sedan tillbaka i bastun.
Utan vi vill att det mer ska vara det naturlösa utan att det inte är någon kravställning på bastun.
Men den skiljer sig lite i kommunikationen beroende på vilken marknad det är.
Om det är viktigt att trycka på de här, så värderar man det.
Har ni haft något problem här under uppskalningen?
Alltså det är en sak att gå från noll till tio miljoner men då är det fortfarande, jag vet att alla tänker att det är en väldigt svår period men då är fortfarande på något sätt lagret hanterbart.
Det är liksom rimliga summor och om två pall inte får plats då kan man alltid gömma det i sin bil eller hemma.
Men någonstans när man börjar skala upp mot kanske för ni har ju ganska stora grejer precis som vi har stora grejer.
Någonstans börjar det bli liksom, fan det här är ju, nu ska vi få in 500 kvadrat här.
Vi kan liksom inte, vi kan inte lägga detta i ett tvättstugan längre.
Hur har ni löst hela den logistiksetappen i takt med att ni har vuxit här?
Det är nog den absolut tuffaste utmaningen som vi har haft nu när vi har skaldat upp och givet att vi har produktionen i Kina så kommer det alltid vara så att det kommer alltid vara kassaflödesutmaning som vi står för i takt med att vi ska hålla det upp.
Och sen hela supplychain-delen.
Första hundra bastel som vi fick in, de handlade vid Viggos restaurang på Södermalm.
Så när vi fick en order så tog vi en taxi dit fem på morgonen, packade ihop den här, satte den utanför, de var välkomna att hämta upp den.
Så varje gång vi fick en order av de här första hundra så var det bara, va, måste man dra till Viggos restaurang och dra ner till källan och packa upp där, det är skitjobb.
Så då satte vi upp ett 3PL som vi har i Helsingborg.
Det har funkat jättebra sen vi satte upp det.
Det är vissa saker i uppsättningen som har varit lite strula, men det har man löst under resans gång.
Men hela logistik, flödet och frakt till kunde är en jätteutmaning som vi har.
Skicka på pall idag, med hemleverans för alla marknader, förutom Norge och UK för UPS, Santor och Frakttjänsten.
Det har du säkert koll på.
Vi gör konstanta förbättringar i hela fraktprocessen, för den är såpass viktig eftersom vi skickar en bast ut till kunden.
Vi behöver kunna kommunicera om vi behöver vara hemma för leveransen, hur skiljer leveransen till, vad behöver jag förbereda i min trädgård.
Det är väldigt komplext och vi sätter väldigt höga krav på oss själva där.
Att vi ska ha den absolut bästa kundeupplevelsen från första köp till bast i bad.
Så det är komplext hela fraktblödet.
Vi lär oss varje dag och vi absolut får lär den.
Hur löser ni er rent likviditetsmässigt här?
Ni är väl rätt vintertunga, man köper kanske ingen bast i på sommaren.
Ni måste ha beställt in en jävla massa mer bastus.
Ni är ju inte så stora att fabriken tycker att ni kan betala tre veckor efter att ni har fått grejerna.
Ni måste ju fortfarande betala en del innan ni har sålt det.
Det är en bra fråga.
När vi lyssnar på många pontar och pratar om att det var tuffa mot fabrikerna och era leverantörer när det kommer till betalningsvillkoren.
Vid redan första kontakt förhandlade vi väldigt hårt om betalningsvillkoren.
Första året var det först att vi skulle bevisa oss att vi kunde sälja de volymerna som vi sa.
Men sen när vi hade bevisat oss, då kunde vi ha den här dialogen på ett mycket bättre sätt.
Idag har vi faktiskt riktigt bra betalningsvillkoren.
Vi har haft det senaste året.
Så det är knappt att vi betalar.
Vi betalade jättemycket när de skickas.
Sedan har vi ungefär två målade på oss till att vi ska betala resterande efter att det kommer till laget i Sverige.
Så det har vi gjort jättemycket för likvidheten.
Men när vi som skulle skala upp hade sålt de första hundra så insåg vi snabbt att vi måste ha en kredit hos banken för att ens kunna köpa in ännu fler i laget.
Så det har varit som steg för steg, hur kan vi förbättra likviditeten över lag så att vi kan skala upp och köpa in ännu fler.
Det är ändå en fruktansvärt bra uppsättning med fabriket.
Att betala två månader efter leverans är ju inte standard i branschen.
Där ska Josef som är ansvarig för det här, han har varit stenhård med det från första början egentligen.
Så att vi måste få de absolut bästa betalningsvillkoren.
För det är en liten osynlig konkurrensfördel som inte jättemånga av våra konkurrenter har koll på.
Men där finns det väldigt mycket.
Då är ju relationen med fabriken jätteviktig.
Man måste åka dit och besöka dem, man måste vara där för produktutveckling, man måste vara där för att verkligen gå igenom alla detaljer och få ett fördjupat partnerskap.
Sen ni tog in en investerare här, han hette Pecka, det var bara av alla investerarnamn en människa kan ha i ett bastubolag, så måste Pecka ha det mest absurdt generiska investerarnamnet, det är fruktansvärt kul.
Och han är finne va?
Nej, man tror det men hans morsa var finne, han är jätteborgare.
Okej, helvetens.
Vi kontaktade honom för det är typ exakt ett år sedan.
För Pecka var tidigare, han var ju högt uppsatt i de Nokia tidigare, och sen gjort lite olika saker.
Han är i alla fall hängt i Finland.
Det har han gjort, för han har varit vd på världens näst största bastuföretag.
Så vi kunde pitcha in hela vår idé, vad vi gör.
Till en början skrev vi att vi säljer bastutält.
Han var direkt på att få en bastutält, hur bra kan det vara?
Sen fick han testa bastutältet, så att vi kunde förklara lite vår strategi överlag och hur vi jämför oss själva, bast versus övriga traditionella bastuföretag.
Han gillade verkligen vår strategi och sen gick han in med en liten slant i somras, och hjälpte oss jättemycket med att öppna upp rättor i bastubranchen.
För det är en väldigt speciell bransch, den är väldigt traditionell på ett sätt.
Så vi behöver ha någon som kan öppna dörren och tre lite yngre grambar som säljer en produkt som många äter en sån koll på.
Ja, jag köper verkligen det, att det kan vara...
För jag gissar att det fungerar så att ganska många fortfarande faktiskt har butiker i er bransch eller det är lite som kaminbranschen.
Alltså det är också ofta, jag kommer inte på vad de här ställena heter, men man åker dit, man kollar, man snackar med någon och så är det vissa märken som säljs in.
Hur stor del av er försäljning är egen e-handel och hur mycket är via alla de här olika set-apperna ni har?
Jag skulle säga att DTC är ungefär 80% och våra återförsäljare ungefär 20%.
Och försäljningen genom återförsäljare, den börjar ju som relativt sett mot totalförsäljaren börjar gå ner, givet att vi skalar upp den egna försäljaren ganska snabbt.
Men samtidigt som båda blir nya återförsäljare runt om i Europa, egentligen, kanske än i veckan.
Så vi håller på att bygga upp den vertikalen också.
För vi har ju, vår strategi överlag är att vara till det först och äga kunden.
De digitala konkurrensfördelarna ska vi verkligen vara bäst på.
Men vi är också i bastibranschen som är väldigt traditionell och vi säljer en produkt för 20.000 och mellan 20.000 och 40.000 det är en produkt som folk vill se, känna och klämma på och kanske prata med någon som kan guida en och ta rätt beslut.
Så vi behöver också ha ett ben i den traditionella bastibranschen där du kan åka till butiken och ställa frågor, känna och så vidare.
Men är det inte, om ni ändå tar så stor andel av försäljningen, är inte allt det där arbetet med partnernätverket och det där bara störigt då?
Om det ändå är 80 procent som ni själva gör?
Ja, men det kan man tycka.
Men jag tror att vad vi ser där, det är att vi får så många förfrågningar från potentiella kunder att säga hej jag bor i Bremen i Tyskland, jag vill verkligen åka till en butik och se det här.
Så vi behöver också skapa de här olika, vi behöver bygga ut hela partnernätverket egentligen så att vi kan låtsa dem dit, för annars hade inte vi fått den försäljningen.
Och vi ser också som ett ganska långsiktigt initiativ att de tar in våra bastel till dag, men sen när vi har byggt upp den relationen och kanske lanserat traditionell bastel i framtiden, så kan vi bara sätta på det direkt och sälja dem till våra butik-
Är det produktutveckling som driver, om vi nu tar nu, jag vet inte, omsatta ni 30 miljoner i år, och då gissar jag att ni ska växa nästa år, eller det är förhoppningen i alla fall.
Är det fler marknader och fler ställen ni ska sälja på då, eller är det nya produkter, eller är det bara att ni ska dubbla lagret och sälja ut det?
Vad är den stora strategin nästa år, eller i år blir det?
Nej men det är lite att dubbla down på det som har funkat, och egentligen bara fortsätta mata på och bli utbarnat verkligt, fortsätta skala på våran adsbudget, fokusera lite mer på det organiska också som vi inte har fokuserat jättemycket på.
Så det är väl det enkla svaret, vi ska bara fortsätta med det vi har gjort och egentligen göra det ännu bättre.
Våra core markets idag är ju Sverige, Norge, Tyskland, och sen UK, Schweiz och Danmark också.
Och det finns så mycket mer att hämta, och jag tror att det finns mycket att hämta att vi kanske vi behåller samma takt i Sverige, men att vi skalar upp Tyskland två, tre, fyra gånger.
För där finns det en väldigt stor marknad och de har en bastu kultur sedan tidigare.
Och det är inte så att vi behöver förklara vad en bastu är, vilket ved man använder, hur det funkar med att kasta på vatten på stenarna.
Och det är vad vi förklarar i UK till exempel.
Där är vi som börjar absolut inte mäta marknaden.
Men det är en mycket mer komplex marknad, givet frakt, givet MOMS-registreringen, returer och hur mycket vi behöver kommunicera.
Så det är mycket att dubba down på de marknader som funkar redan idag.
Det känns som Australien och sådana länder kan vara bastu-folk.
Nu vet jag att det är varmt i Australien, jag fattar det, men jag bodde där ett år när jag var yngre och pluggade.
Då är det väldigt mycket strandkultur, man hänger där.
Det är extremt mycket surfinkultur.
Jag bara tänker att de hade nog gärna suttit i en bastu också.
Jag vet inte, det blir en dyr satsning om vi går in där.
Vi har kanske fått typ 25 förfågningar från kronor i Australien, men om vi går in i Australien då är det direkt genom en distributör som köper in en container per gång.
För annars blir det lite väl komplex för oss.
Det är väl det ensamma det vi har med distributörer för vissa marknader.
Vi kanske inte känner att vi har haft lika bra penetration över lag och att vi kan lämna mycket av den egna försäljningen till dem.
Polen är ett sånt exempel där vi håller på att undersöka med en distributör just nu.
För där har vi som inte haft jättemycket intresse, inte jättemycket försäljning, men det är en marknad vi tror på.
Så kanske börja och undersöka den marknaden genom en distributör och sen kan vi sätta på våra egna processer och dit att se.
Ni har ju ganska dyra grejer.
Alltså jag säger inte att tältet säger dyrt, men produkten är ju dyr för att vara en e-handelsprodukt.
Vad är problematiken med det?
Är det extremt långa kundresor?
Är det sjukt mycket kundservice och frågor?
Eller är folk väldigt anala när det kommer till här?
Det var lite smuts på den här duken här.
Men jag har ju lagt 20 000 på detta, jag vill ha fina skruvar.
Vad är problematiken med att ha en dyr produkt?
Jag skulle säga att om vi pratar om kundresan och längden på kundresan och hur mycket vi behöver utbilda kunder.
Först och främst är vi i bastbranschen, våra målgrupper mellan typ 40-65, oftast män som har väldigt detaljerade frågor.
Vad är den jobbigaste frågebatteriet du har fått?
Vilken är den jobbigaste kunden?
Kommer du ihåg vad han ställer för frågor?
Det var en kille, det vet vi.
Det brukar oftast vara, har du gjort lumpen och är runt 60-bass, så har du alltid frågor som är såhär var det på min tid när jag gjorde lumpen.
Det här är inte alls.
Absolut, absolut.
De frågorna som vi får är väldigt högt och lågt.
Det är allt ifrån blir det varmt och det kommunicerar vi överallt.
Men hur sätter man upp det?
Hur länge tar det från att kaminen kyls ner till att man kan packa ihop ett dra?
Behövs det bynklov?
Så de frågorna som vi får är alltid återkommande.
Så vi försöker att besvara dem i våra ads eller på hemsidan på produktbilderna direkt, kanske på produktbilderna och ditt illustration är kopplat till dem.
Men den bästa gissningen vi har hur lång kundresa den är, det är egentligen från e-mail-subscriber till tjej.
Och den ligger på ungefär hundra dagar.
Så det är en väldigt lång kundresa och vi behöver utbilda dem.
Det är komplext och sen när det kommer till kravställning från kunder givet priset på produkten, så är det att allt ska sitta.
Det får inte vara ett litet fel i produkten.
Vi har ett värdeskydd till exempel som vi säljer som man sätter över tälten för att skida mot uvestrådning.
Och om ventilationen sitter lite fel på det, då får vi ett supportförande.
Så vi behöver egentligen vara fläckfria i alla processer givet den höga prisbilden.
Från början var ju gymmetsrustning till exempel extremt Ikea-style.
Alltså varje skruvlåge löst för att det var enklast att skicka på det sättet.
Det var folk kunde montera för 15 år sedan.
Men nu har vi märkt att det blir väldigt mycket supportärenden och krångel när man gör så.
Så att även om frakten blir lite dyrare, så har vi på rätt mycket produkter börjat förmontera så mycket som går för att det bara gör det enklare.
Har ni också varit i den problematiken eller?
Ja, vi har varit exakt i den problematiken.
De här skruvarna funkar inte, det är du som inte funkar.
Exakt, vi har bara varit sjukt frustrerade på vissa kunder som har avsett att de gör rent av fel.
Men då kommer det ändå tillbaka till att vår kommunikation i manual börjar vara bättre eller how to videos börjar vara bättre.
Men det exempel som du nämner, vi har exakt gjort det.
Förut var vi tvungna att montera kaminen och skruva på värmeskydd som man har för att man ska inte bränna benen om det sitter på nära kaminen.
Förut var kunderna tvungna att montera de här själva.
Men sen in så vi fick så pass många frågor, så det är mer rimligt att vi ska vara på dem direkt i fabriken och skicka dem så, och att vi kanske får några taktskador.
Men det är lättare att hantera dem än att hantera varje kund som har rör av sig och säga att hela processen att skruva ihop kaminen är hemskt.
Vi har haft så många ärenden av, förlåt alla kunder jag hänger ut nu, men det är så många ärenden där folk har skruvat i skruvar och så, säger de, men det wobblar ju.
Säger man, du har inte ens skruvat in skruven, eller du har liksom inte ens dragit åt den.
Jo jag har skruvit så hårt jag kan.
Ja för hand då eller?
Ja för hand.
Men du använder väl en skiftnyckel när du drar åt en skruv.
Det är väl ingen människa som drar åt.
Men jag ska inte, vi vet alla att det är i Stockholm, det är ju inte vanliga människor liksom.
Det är inte Luleå.
Nej, apropå det nu, ni verkar ju bo i Stockholm allihopa, hur länge ska ni fejka Norrlands dialekt?
För att det gör ni ju bara för ökad försäljning och varumärkesstil.
Vad är er riktiga dialekt nu?
Hur länge har ni bott i Stockholm?
Jag har inte bott allt för länge, jag har bott här i fem år, vi har bott här i typ tio år, Josef har bott i sju år.
Men det blir så att vi hänger bara med varandra, och vi är ett stort Luleå-ängar i Stockholm.
Så vi har väl inte klimatiserats jättebra i Stockholm överlag.
Så vi har bibehållt dialekten på grund av att vi bara pratar med varandra.
Är ni stereotyrer, nu jag vet inte hur jag sa det i början, men jag är för del Luleå, men jag flyttade ju så tidigt så att jag räknas som ultraförädare.
Jag är ju bara fake, jag tar creden men jag har liksom inget riktigt i blodet så att säga.
Men är ni sådana på riktigt, ni sitter och tittar in i en vägg och så tycker ni att ni har haft en ganska bra eftermiddag?
Eller är ni sociala?
Jag ska ju säga att vi är väldigt sociala med varandra.
Det är det vi har som vår lilla klipp, vi är bästa kompisar och vad gör ni?
Vad blir det?
Jag och Jose riktigt på tagis tillsammans.
Sedan lärde vi känna viggor när vi våttade.
Så vi är väldigt sociala med varandra men utanför det kanske inte lika mycket.
Så vi är väl någorlunda utåtriktade luleboer.
Jag vet inte om det låter älskvärt eller inte.
Ja men utåtriktade som luleboer är som rätt tråkig typ.
Öresunds, jag vet inte.
Du sa ju att ni är tre polare som startar.
Ni var väl tre redan från starten.
Det var väl ni som drog igång det så att säga.
Man säger ju alltid att man inte ska starta bolag med polare och sånt där för att det kan bli lite knepigt.
Gjorde ni det som en skojgrej eller gick ni liksom in i det och skrev upp olika aktieavtal och olika du ska göra det här, jag ska göra det här, det här förväntas.
Hur har den resan sett ut och utvecklats genom åren?
Jag tror att vi från att vi fick idén till att vi verkligen kommer överens att vi skrev ett ärligt försök, så vi har ändå varit ganska professionella i allt.
Allt från att sätta upp aktieägaravtalet tidigt till att det första vi gjorde när vi insåg att vi kör, det var att vi hade ett möte och så gick vi igenom, vad är det värsta som kan hända om vi startar det här?
Och så gick vi igenom att vi kan bli ovänder, det är inte skitkul, vi kan förlora alla våra besparingar och det kan gå ut över jobben som vi hade då och våra relationer också.
Så vi satte som förväntningarna ganska tidigt, men vi ska köra ordentligt och satte också rollerna väldigt kul.
Så vi körde på ganska hårt från start och vad är det för att det har funkat så bra?
Det är väl att vi har hållit förväntningarna väldigt tydliga på varandra, men också att vi känner varandra ut och in.
Och är det så att Wingo kanske hade en jobbig dag på sin restaurang, då kunde jag steppa in och täcka upp för honom och vice versa.
Så om det är någon man vill jobba stenhårt för, även fast man själv behöver jobba lite hårt och ordra det så är det sina bästa kompisar.
Så vi har haft en väldigt fint samspel där.
Men sedan är det också knepigt att starta det med sina kompisar.
Men vi är verkligen bästa kompisar.
Och vi hade turen att vi alla hade olika kompetenser som gjorde att vi kompletterade varandra väldigt bra.
Så jag skulle säga att tydliga förväntningar är skitviktigt.
Ska vi basta ihop lite kompisprojekt eller ska vi ta över världen?
Vi kommer överens om att vi ska ta över världen.
Och hur ser en vanlig vardag ut?
När behöver jag steppa upp för vinkorna?
Behöver han steppa upp för mig?
Och när behöver jag steppa upp för Josef?
Det tror jag också är jätteviktigt.
Så ha löpande kommunikation i vartiden och det avvinner att bli bästa kompetenter.
Har det varit problem med hur ni ska ta de tuffa besluten eller vem som ska bestämma?
Alltså vi är tre stycken, så det är alltid majoritet i besluten.
Är det så?
Ja, det har varit jätteskönt.
Så om det är två mot en, då blir det två mot en.
Och sen behöver vi vara väldigt prestigelösa om ens egna förslag har satsats ner.
Så det har varit en superfördel.
Men sen har vi också en process om det är så att när man verkligen lägger in sitt bet och att det är två mot en eller med jag som har blivit nerröstad, då kan man ta det vidare.
Så nu har vi några rådgivare som vi jobbar med.
Så då kan vi bolla med dem.
Jag fattar, är det Pecka som får stoppa in då och liksom säga vem som har rätt?
Exakt, då kommer vi med kloka bastningssikten.
Har ni de här tydliga, är det en produktnisse, en marknadsföringsnisse och en finansnisse eller vad är era kompetenser?
Vi kan börja med Josef.
Han har ju drivit bolag kanske i typ tio år i olika, jag kommer från företag och familj.
De har kläbutiker uppe i Norrbotten.
Så han hade tydligen CFO ansvar och jag skulle säga COO överlag.
Bingo har varit ansvarig för contentdelen och hela brandet, så mycket av det kreativa.
Och jag har varit ansvarig för sälj.
Så alltifrån våra partnertverk till vår hemsida till alla e-handelsprocesser egentligen.
Så vi hade en ganska bra mix av det där, att Josef kunde hålla oss flytande hela tiden, att vi behöver ha alla avtal på plats, bokföringen behöver sitta, produktutvecklingen, vi alla har delat lite på den.
Men Josef också ägde den, och sen vi går det kreativt och vi vet genom e-handeln, det behövs ganska mycket bulk av content, så det tar sjukt mycket tid.
Det var att jag var ansvarig för, ja men du säljer det och bara maximerar det.
Ja, jag bara kände spontant, för visst var det Josef som förhandlade fram de här avtalen med betaltiderna.
Är det någon ni som lyssnar om, är det någon ni ska sno från företaget och ge en riktigt jävla bizarr lön som han lämnar sina vänner, så ta Josef, för jag tror att det är svårt att förstå hur bra förhandlat det där är om man inte har suttit i de där rummen.
Det är bra gjort.
Det är otroligt.
Hamnade ni också i den här, de har ju en tendens, det är ju fortfarande så i stora delar av Asien när man gör affärer och gör tunga förhandlingar, att man måste dricka väldigt mycket.
Skickade ni fram Josef då?
Nej, det var inte så.
Nej men han är nykterist.
Oj, då är det ännu, jag vill bara säga, då borde han verkligen bli rekryterad.
Det är starkt jobbat.
Det är tungt att jag har all cred till Josef utan att ha träffat honom.
Vad är nästa, du har liksom nämnt här att vi ska double down, men om man verkligen ska ta den stora problematiken nu, om ni ska upp och bli, alltså quotation marks på något sätt, ett riktigt stort bolag som, nu är det 20 anställda och vi är etablerade som aktör.
Vad är det ni förbereder er på?
Har ni tänkt så långt eller är ni fortfarande bara inne i mata på mode?
Alltså vi har ju varit inne i mata på mode egentligen sedan vi startade.
Sedan började vi som ett målsättningsarbete och strategiarbete egentligen i januari i år.
Där vi som första gången på väldigt länge verkligen tagit ett steg tillbaka och blickat framåt.
Det är väldigt svårt hur vi ska nå vår långsiktiga strategi.
Vi vill ju bli världens största basseföretag.
Vi tror också att det är möjligt givet vår strategi att vara digital first om man jämför med bassebranschen i stort.
Men jag tror under 2016 som blir det absolut viktigaste för oss det är att bygga ut teamet och frigöra ännu mer tid för oss att verkligen kunna sitta med långsiktig initiativ.
Vi har precis nu i veckan anställt en kille inom kundservice som är kanon.
Vi behöver anställa igenom content också för att frigöra VIG och Stida och jobba med lite andra initiativ som vi tror väldigt mycket på.
Så jag skulle säga i år är det jätteviktigt att bygga ut teamet och sen får vi se vart vi kommer med de resurserna.
Är det, men när du säger basseföretag ni ska även in i riktiga basse här men träbyggda basse här.
Det är planen och jag skulle säga att Bastetel kommer nog vara vårt fokus kanske kommande tre år.
Men sen är tanken att det ska löpa ett parallellt projekt där vi utforskar en permanent kamin som vi kan ha inomhus men också i en trästuga.
Också själva trästugan för bastun.
Så det är planen och det är väldigt komplext och jag tror inte vi inser redan nu hur komplext det kommer vara.
Men det är vår ambition och varför vi har satt det som vision är för att vi tror att det finns möjligheter för oss att uppnå det och bli världens största bastuföretag.
Konkurrensen är hård, det är den absolut, men det är inte som att starta techbolag i Stockholm och du konkurrerar med väldigt hög konkurrensnivå överlag.
För vi tror att det finns en möjlighet.
Sen har vi bollor här med PEC också.
Vår strategi är att verkligen sätta kundeupplevelsen nummer ett och allt som växer prio.
Det gör att vi kommer att ha en helt annan strategi mot övriga bastuföretag som bara är duktiga på produkt, har ett distributionsnätverk, skickar du ut det här till Bauhaus och de i sin tur säljer, men man bryr sig aldrig om kunden eller du äger aldrig kunden.
Så vi tror att det är möjligt.
Finns det en risk i er återköpsfrekvens måste vara typ noll.
Ni kanske säljer någon bänk eller en spade typ, eller vad man nu kallar en slev som man skickar vatten med.
Jag gissar att ni säljer det.
Men det måste vara ganska mycket så att när man har sålt någonting då har man inte den kunden sedan på 10-15 år.
Exakt.
Det är en av våra absolut största utmaningar som vi behöver hantera.
Hur vi hanterar återkommande kunder eller hur vi försöker maximera så mycket värde av våra kunder det är att första köpet vi behöver maxa av.
Hur gör vi det?
Vi jobbar med bandel, så vi har ett basic paket, vi har ett pluspaket, ett premepaket och ett deluxpaket.
Vi försöker alltid att det första köpet är så högt så böjligt att vi maxar direkt.
Sen har vi som andra delen att vi alltid utvecklar nya produkter som vi kan lägga till i befintliga paket.
Ett sånt exempel är som ett värmeskydd som man kan ha runt kaminen för att maximera säkerhet i kvala att det är en barnfamilj som har köpt ett bastfält.
Men sen är det en långsiktig initiativ att kunden som köper ett bastfält ska ha världens bästa upplevelse med oss som varumärke.
Och sen i sprutande när man ska köpa en permanent lösning, då väljer man oss.
Varför har ni inte gått in i typ, jag vet inte vad man har när man bastar men någonstans hörde jag om några som sålde såhär, att man lade i bastun och så luktade det på något viss sätt eller rensade typ snorhålen.
Ni har aldrig funderat på att gå in i den där världen.
Jo, vi håller på att göra det.
Vi har även något som heter Sauna Ice.
Sauna Ice var det jag hörde exakt.
Vi har haft samma möte på de länge.
Men de är klockorna, de är skitduktiga.
Så det kan ju vara ett sätt att maxa ut värdet.
Men det är ofta så, köper du tre med paket, då ingår ju det här Sauna Ice.
Vår strategi kommer att vara när det kommer till återkommande köp med metolkristaller eller olika basteldofter.
Det är väl främst då för att få in dem i vårt ekosystem och sen bearbeta dem och sen sälja en bastel.
När du ser att ni om några år funderar på att då kanske man går in i platsbyggda bastor, eller stora, man kan ju köra dem på, man kan ju rulla in dem också, man kan ju köpa en lös basto eller vad man ska säga.
Men jag fattar att det är samma segment, att det är basto, men det är ju inte riktigt samma grej, det är ju en helt annan produktion.
Är ni inte rädda att ni ska fucka upp där lite grann?
Det är vi absolut.
Tanken var att vi skulle börja med redan i år, men vi tog ett beslut att vi säger nej till det kommande tre åren, att bara fokusera på Bastotel, för det finns så mycket mer att hämta.
Sen tror jag att vår ambition är att nå dit, men sen kommer det säkert komma jättemycket utmaningar på vägen där vi kanske inser att det här var lite för komplext för oss.
Så vi har inte alla svar på de frågorna nu om det kommer vara möjligt att konkurrera med hjärtarna när det kommer till en permanenta lösning.
Fan, jag fastnar i det här lite men det är för att det är spännande.
Men har ni inte kopplat emot kallbadsgrejen?
Ni har inte börjat tänka på att sälja kallbadstunnor och sånt, för det är ju också lite kopplat till Bastur på något sätt.
Nej men vi gör det.
Ni gör det redan?
Ja det är klart ni gör.
Fan vad dålig researchar mig.
Hur går det?
Säljer det på någonting?
Inte jättemycket om man köper dem separat.
Jag skulle säga att anledningen till det är att vi inte pushar det överhuvudtaget i våra marknadsföring och vi använder främst kopplat till Bandrads.
Så köp ett Bastutell och få ett isbad på köpet.
Så isbaden använder vi främst till både app-selling, men också kanske främst som en kampanjprodukt som vi kan pusha ut i våra befintliga, men också få folk att talas för ett beslut och köpa ett Bastutell.
Det är ju ett köp som inte måste göra idag idag idag.
Så vi måste alltid få över kunden så fort som möjligt och ta ett beslut.
Ja, Sebastian ett stort stort tack för att du var med i podden och lycka till.
Vi ser fram emot att jag gissar att målet då är att slå i hundringen om två år.
Ni har säkert den ambitionen eller tre år om ni är lite trötta av er.
Men eftersom ni tredubblade förra året så har ni säkert sagt om två år.
Vad har ni satt för mål?
Vi har i år initialt vår tredubbla igen.
Det var väl lite för aggressivt.
Har vi insett nu när vi har kommit in i 2026.
Så mest roligt att dubbla är målsättning.
Jag tror det är ganska bra att säga det publikt att det är svart att dubbla.
Exakt.
För om vi inte lyckas med det så kommer jag skömma ut mig helt ålderligt.
Jag kommer sampla det och göra en remix på Youtube.
Det är målsättning och sen kommer vi ha väldigt mycket utmaningar.
Men jag tror absolut att det är möjligt.
Yes, vi säger stort tack och stort lycka till.
Som mest roligt att dubbla är målsättningen.
Jag tror det är ganska bra att säga det publiskt att du ska dubbla.
Jag kommer sampla det och göra en remix på YouTube.
Jag vill också titta på YouTube Som mest troligt för domplar Ni gör det redan, det är klart ni gör.